good afternoon everyone
my name is amarjad sandhu and i'm the
member of provincial parliament for the
great riding of brampton west
in queen's park it is my duty to listen
to my constituents and understand how
can we help them
what i hear is that the people of
brampton want opportunities close to
where they live
to learn to work to raise families
and they want to increase the healthcare
workforce to be prepared to handle our
rapidly growing population
under previous government brampton was
neglected for far too long i'm proud to
be a strong advocate for this city
premier ford
mr sirkarias of elliot
and dunlop and i all agree that brampton
must get its fair share
there's so much talent and skill in our
great city
brampton is one of the youngest cities
in the country
that is why our government is focused on
helping the youth in our community grow
and prosper
everyone here has worked tirelessly to
ensure that the people of brampton get
the opportunities they deserve
i'm honored to invite the premier of
ontario doug ford to the podium to
announce one more way that this
government is delivering for the people
and families of membrane thank you
well good morning everyone and thank you
mpp sandu for that introduction
you're a big reason why we're here today
making this announcement
we're also joined by minister dunlaw
minister elliott and councillor
charmaine williams which we're all
instrumental in this
and as well as the person that controls
the money as i always say i love the
people who control the money the
president of the treasury board private
sicario
who has done an outstanding job
delivering for the people of brampton
south
also as i say the architect the
commander-in-chief
dr mohammad lashemi from ryerson
university who has been leading the
charge to make this incredible
announcement possible dr lashoni thank
you thank you for all your leadership
and your work
friends after two very long years we've
come so far
because of the sacrifices made by
ontarians and the amazing care provided
by our healthcare heroes we've been able
to safely and cautiously reopen our
province
after decades of under investment this
pandemic stretched our system to the
limit
but now looking ahead
we can be confident that ontario is
better prepared for the future
we're producing more of the masks gowns
gloves goggles face shields and
ventilators we need here at home
because of our ambitious plan that's
building ontario
we're adding thousands of hospital and
long-term care beds
with the support of our government's
historic funding
fast growing towns like brampton are
attracting more doctors nurses and
personal support workers to care for
patients
but we can do more to build a stronger
more resilient health system
a big part of that is ensuring we're
training the next generation of
world-class health professionals
and making sure that we are providing
the opportunities for more women and men
to get the schooling they need to become
the doctors of tomorrow
that is why i'm proud to announce our
government is making a major expansion
to the medical education in ontario and
adding 160 undergraduate positions and
295 postgraduate positions to ontario's
medical schools
this is the largest expansion in more
than 10 years and it will create more
spaces at all six medical schools across
the province
further delivering on our promise to
bring high quality health care to all
parts of ontario
but most exciting of all we're building
the brand new ryerson school of medicine
that will open right here in brampton
our government is investing in training
the doctors who will serve this
community
at a new hospital for brampton that we
announced last summer
we want doctors from this community
trained in this community
serving this community
ontario's doctors are some of the finest
in the entire world we've seen that
proven every day over the last two years
with this investment we're supporting
more students to take the path to
becoming a doctor
and creating the family doctors and
specialists that will take care of us in
the years to come
and we're bringing these opportunities
to our growing cities like brampton
where there is so much talent and strong
desire for people to give back to their
communities
this is just one part of our efforts to
strengthen our health care workforce
including adding 5 000 new and upskilled
registered nurses
and registered practical nurses
as well as 8 000 more personal support
workers with these investments we're
putting the health of ontarians first
and building a stronger health care
system for the years to come
our province has come so far
and we can't afford to go back to the
politics of known instead your
government is saying yes
yes to training more doctors and nurses
yes to investing in our communities and
yes to building a stronger more
resilient province
friends let's say yes to the better and
brighter future that the people of
ontario deserve
thank you and god bless the people of
ontario
now i'll hand it over to my good friend
dr
show me
[Applause]
thank you very much premier ford
this is a great news for the people of
brampton and pele region
i want to thank all of the government
representatives who have played a part
in making this a reality
i would also like to extend a special
thank you to dr frank martino
interim
president and ceo of the william osler
health system who is here with us today
throughout this pandemic
the government's decisions have been
guided by concern for the well-being of
the people of this province
that same focus brings us here today
for the past two years the people of
brampton and peel and horizon university
have been working to shape plans for a
new kind of a medical medical school
an innovative school that reflects the
needs of this diverse and fast growing
region
brampton deserves a medical school that
is based on the kind of health care
this community needs today's
announcement is a major investment
in the future of brampton
and we thank premier
ford and his government for this
demonstration of confidence in ryerson
to help make this happen thank you very
much
[Applause]
when i update questions from the media
if reporters with questions could please
form a line behind me at the microphone
it'll be one question and one follow-up
per reporter one at a time
premiere good morning it's richard with
city news richard i'm good thank you
unfortunately we've seen this b82
subvarian cause a lot of trouble
overseas half of european countries are
seeing cases surge hospitalizations too
scotland within the last hour decided to
reverse its plan to drop its mass
mandate hospitals in hong kong are
overrun 37 million locked down in china
premiere i'm wondering what you think
about when you hear these reports
well we're always very cautious i just
want to remind everyone per capita we
have the lowest hospitalizations i think
next to pei
but always be cautious and move forward
uh slowly and
and uh we've built up our health care
system we've built up our health care
system to be handed to be able to handle
uh an increase and we've learned a
tremendous amount over the last two
years but uh maybe i'll bring minister
elliot up
that's
deals with this day in and day out
well we have been following the ba2
variant very closely dr moore is
studying it we expect that it may be the
50
of the cases we have in ontario within
the next short period of time
but the evidence suggests that in
ontario at least it is a variant of the
original omicron variant and it's not
causing any more hospitalizations or
more intensive treatments but we're
keeping a very close eye on it
and are very cognizant of what's going
on in the rest of the world but as the
premier said we have built up our system
we've built up another 3 100 extra beds
we're training the health human
resources as
with this announcement today and
dr moore feels that we will be able to
handle this variant without any further
disruption to services in ontario thank
you minister um premier on the mass
mandate which you're dropping next
monday a number of uh colleges and
universities and private schools have
decided to keep the mandate in place for
their students how can they get to make
that decision without jumping through
any hoops but the public boards don't
sir
well again that's going to be up to each
university in each
college
we have our minister here minister
dunlop you want to speak on that
yeah
thank you
thank you premier and thank you for that
question uh as you know universities and
colleges are autonomous legal entities
so they are able to make those academic
and administrative decisions for
themselves
hello premier natasha mcdonald radio
canada
come here will you be supporting patrick
brown
or any other candidate in the federal
conservative
leadership race and will you be allowing
your mps ministers to publicly support
the candidate of virtuous well great
great question um the answer is no i'll
be supporting the people of ontario i
have my hands full
moving forward
and as for mpps i believe they'll have
their hands full so
no
they won't be supporting anyone
mr mcnaughton this morning was talking
about 30 30 000 jobs for ukrainian
refugees but your government has yet to
allocate specific funds or say
for reset limits resettlement or say
where those refugees would be housed so
can you give any details on that and say
if uh any of those jobs would be
available as well for afghan
sure we welcome everyone first of all
let me address what's happening in
ukraine my heart breaks for the people
over there they're so resilient they're
some of the strongest people i've ever
seen and uh fighting against this tyrant
in which the whole world has to fight
against this tyrant
and as for the people coming here we
welcome them with open arms
we have over 200 companies and 30
000 positions available and that's just
the 200 companies that have come forward
uh would be working with settlement
services as well
our goal is to make sure they have safe
haven when they come here and we'll make
sure that that happens and again we have
a tremendous amount of opportunities for
them employment uh here in ontario uh i
guess the federal government's job is to
get them here once they're here uh
they'll be well taken care of not only
within the ukrainian community but from
everyone in ontario
hi premier holly mckenzie cedar with
canadian press i'm asking you about the
psw wage increase that was temporary and
extended since 2020 can you just explain
why you can make it permanent now after
all this time rather than you know in
2020 and related to that why take this
approach of giving raises to particular
health worker groups rather than just
get rid of the build 124 like they're at
the unions they're asking for
to allow higher wages well thanks for
that question we've seen over the last
two years uh
how they've stepped up to the plate
they've done an incredible job and we
saw the challenges of long-term care
who stepped up all the psws
for years they were ignored they were
underpaid overworked and we acknowledge
that by giving them uh the three dollar
an hour increase we are going to make it
permanent and uh it's well deserving uh
there's they worked so hard and we all
saw it firsthand
on another topic college professors
instructors and other academic staff are
planning to go on strike friday if the
colleges don't agree to send their
negotiations to binding and just
arbitration what's your reaction to that
and you think the timing of a full
strike makes sense i don't like when
anyone goes on on strike especially in
these conditions when we went through
such tough times but again i'll call my
great minister up here
well thank you for the question and uh
you know we are monitoring the uh the
process quite closely i've heard from
students and from parents who are very
upset students cannot afford a strike at
this time they're finally back in the
classroom that's where they need to be
that's where their best education is
where they're collaborating with their
colleagues and their faculty we've seen
the resiliency of faculty students and
colleges come together during comet to
ensure that students continue their
education and so i hope to see everyone
back to the table and making sure that
we respect the the bargaining and uh
come to uh a
is that grant for deal random guardians
um i'm wondering about the timelines for
the medical school
when they're planning on opening and
it's gonna happen
well we'll do it as quickly as possible
but i'm gonna send it over as i joke
around with them the commander-in-chief
doctor
thank you very much for the question
in terms of timing we have to work with
the community and we have engaged
the community here in brampton and the
peter region in many conversations we'll
continue those conversations we are also
actually in conversation with the uh
with the city of brampton because it's
important to work with
with the leadership of the council there
in terms of timing
i think we are very optimistic about the
first court of student in september
2025.
next question will be just about the
hospital the uh
memorial expansion or were you any
updates on that or where are we at on
that uh biology still planned for
opening in 2023 or it is it is and i
hate to keep passing the questions
because this falls under the
minister so maybe the minister of health
can come up but it with that we're going
to move as quickly as possible if they
need mzos uh we'll issue the mzos to get
that hospital up and going they were
ignored uh from the previous
administration for decades this is a
growing community
and we need to make sure that they
aren't forgotten about
we certainly know that people at
brampton need more health services and
we have already invested over 18 million
dollars in expanding the care that's
available uh 24 7 through the clinic but
we're also working very closely with
them to get the
final drawings ready as soon as possible
move them through the
ministry and get the shovels in the
ground as quickly as we can
this will be the last question
hey good morning premiere
on the psw pay i know part of the hurdle
before was
you were giving money to the uh
corporations which then had to give the
money to
the pslv how did you guys figure a way
around that hurdle are you guys paying
the pslv directly could you take us
through that
well again i'm going to go back to the
reason why they got the paid column they
got the pay because they've worked their
back off and they've been ignored for
many many years from the previous
administration
now we're going to implement it as a
permanent uh pay hike it's a three
dollar increase and it's well deserving
okay on another topic masking so next
monday the return of the legislature of
course what are you telling your
progressive conservative mpps are they
allowed to in the legislature wear their
masks if they want to or
is the edict from the printer's office
you know march 21st masks off we'd like
you to keep your masks off no that's
going to be
up to them and it's really again up to
the speaker which has done an incredible
job and i'll say this about all parties
um no matter if it's uh the green the
libs the dippers or or the pcs
um you know everyone's gonna follow the
proper protocols and if you want to keep
your mask on god bless you you can you
can keep your mask on and if you don't
then that's that's fine too but i always
side on the error of caution
and uh for the first few days i'll
i'll be keeping my mask on
thank you
thank you thanks everyone
[Applause]